las mascarillas se han convertido en el
símbolo indiscutible de la pandemia de
coronavirus en el futuro les contaremos
a nuestros nietos como teníamos que
llevar la mascarilla a todas partes
durante los años que duró la pandemia
del sars coronavirus 2 sin embargo si te
dijera que durante los primeros meses de
la pandemia la oms se desaconsejaba el
uso de la máscara
tal vez lo hayáis olvidado pero hubo un
tiempo donde muchos epidemiólogos y
hasta divulgadores científicos dedicaron
vídeos enteros explicando por qué no
teníamos que usar la mascarilla en aquel
momento tanto youtube como el resto de
plataformas publicaron unas reglas para
evitar las técnicos con respecto al
coronavirus una de estas reglas era no
contradecir los consejos de la oms a fin
de cuentas la o ms es la mayor autoridad
sanitaria en todo el mundo si hay
alguien que pueda decir lo que es verdad
o lo que es mentira en el mundo de la
medicina esa es la organización mundial
de la salud sin embargo ahora sabemos
que las mascarillas son útiles para
evitar los contagios de coronavirus y
que la oms también tiene sus intereses
políticos dicho de otra forma que si
hasta la unam s se equivoca a la hora de
determinar qué es y qué no es una
afección cómo podemos evitar los bulos
en internet cómo podemos identificarlos
de verdad se puede censurar estos bulos
sin cercenar la libertad de expresión
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes vamos a explicaros cómo
podéis saltarnos todos los firewalls y
ver el contenido que queráis en internet
sin censura y de forma segura sabéis
cómo hacerlo
exacto utilizando una vpn como surf
shark vpn
[Música]
sol usar no sólo nos permite ver páginas
webs de cualquier país sino que además
nos permite hacerlo sin miedo a llenar
nuestro ordenador en nuestro teléfono
móvil de virus y creedme el tema de la
ciberseguridad se lo toman muy pero que
muy en serio por ejemplo sus arts tienen
una herramienta que se llama clean web
que bloquea todos esos popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bots y de cookies que francamente no
queremos tener
por si todo esto fuera poco con una
única cuenta del surf shark vpn podrás
registrar todos los dispositivos que
quieras quieres navegar con seguridad
desde tu smart tv o desde tu teléfono
móvil o desde tu ordenador pues puedes
hacer todo esto con una única cuenta de
surf shark vpn y por supuesto tenemos un
descuento de lujo para todos vosotros
que seguís visual política si utilizáis
el código político terminado en capte
visual política tendréis un 83 por
ciento de descuento más tres meses extra
totalmente gratuitos tenéis los links en
la descripción no esperéis más y
descargaros ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay dos ideas que siempre se nos olvidan
cuando hablamos del debate de la censura
y de las baking el primero es que no
sólo hablamos de libertad de expresión
también hablamos del trabajo de mucha
gente pensarlas y visual polític no es
solamente un medio de comunicación
también es una pequeña empresa que nos
da de comer a todos los que hemos creado
[Música]
si de repente un día youtube decidiera
quitarnos el canal nos veríamos en la
calle de un día para otro sería como si
de repente todos los centros comerciales
del mundo decidieran echar a todos los
taras hablaríamos de miles de personas
en la calle en este caso no hablamos de
tanta gente en la calle pero aún así no
deja de ser una auténtica guarrada pero
no sólo eso otro de los grandes errores
al hablar de este tema es hablar de las
big tex por igual el mismo donald trump
ha denunciado por igual tanto a twitter
como a facebook como alphabet es decir
el grupo donde está google youtube y lo
cierto es que hablamos de tres empresas
completamente distintas aquí tenéis a la
fea de youtube susan wojcicki aquí
tenemos al ceo de facebook mark
zuckerberg y el último pero no por ello
menos importante el teo de twitter jack
dorsey y de verdad que dados con la cara
de jack dorsey porque va a ser muy
importante en esta historia
como os lo puedo decir habéis oído
alguna vez de eso de que las apariencias
engañan pues creedme jack dorsey es un
ejemplo de que a veces las apariencias
no engañan para nada pero de eso
hablaremos más adelante ahora vamos a
centrarnos en el fenómeno de las page
news a atentos
[Música]
cuando ya no sabemos lo que es verdad
puede que sorprenda pero las picnics no
son ningún invento de nuestra época pues
puedo dar un ejemplo de nada menos que
el año 1898 este fue el año en el que
estalló la guerra entre españa y cuba
guerra donde eeuu apoyo al bando cubano
pues bien todo esto empezó por una
noticia falsa publicada en un periódico
the morning journal probablemente este
nombre esta cabecera no os diga gran
cosa pero muchos conoceréis a su
fundador de hecho hablamos de él en el
vídeo de la semana pasada william
randolph hearst
y seguro que muchos habréis oído alguna
vez su famosa frase esta es literalmente
la frase que dijo hertz al periodista
que escribió la noticia usted ponga las
fotos y yo pongo la guerra william
randolph hearst fundador de the morning
journal la diferencia es que ahora
tenemos internet esto significa que cada
vez más gente puede tener un medio de
comunicación y llegar a audiencias
globales y todo esto significa una
palabra competencia
[Música]
hace solo 20 años cada país tenía unos
pocos periódicos de tirada nacional esos
periódicos se repartían la audiencia y
la tarta publicitaria entre muy poca
gente los ingresos permitían pagar
grandes plantillas y grandes rotativas
si habéis visto la redacción de
cualquier periódico tradicional habréis
visto que son auténticas fábricas una
rotativa no es más que una fábrica de
hacer periódicos y os aseguro que es de
todo menos barata la redacción de un
periódico como por ejemplo the new york
times' puede tener cientos de
trabajadores sin embargo ahora todos
estos medios tradicionales compiten con
los periódicos online
los precios de la publicidad son cada
vez más bajos y los grandes medios
siguen teniendo muchas facturas que
pagar a esto hay que sumarle otro factor
sólo el 30 por ciento de los lectores de
periódicos entra directamente en las
páginas web el resto hacen clic a través
de noticias que encuentran en redes
sociales todo esto explica una carrera
salvaje por conseguir más clics que
nadie y todo esto explica también porque
a menudo nos encontramos con titulares
como éste el porno en streaming produce
tanto co2 como bélgica new scientist 11
de julio 2019 pensando bien un vídeo de
visual político como este que estáis
viendo ahora requiere días enteros de
investigación estos son horas de trabajo
una noticia falsa o una noticia poco
rigurosa es mucho más barata de escribir
se puede hacer en solamente unos minutos
y puede generar tanto más tráfico basta
con que confirmen nuestros sesgos
ideológicos para que la demos por buena
la leamos y sobre todo la compartamos
pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
todos todo esto es un problema pero esto
no son las técnicas como tal sin embargo
todos sabemos que hay auténticas fake
news es decir noticias que no es que
sean sensacionalistas
per preta bless sino que son
directamente falsas incluso muchas de
estas noticias se publican en páginas
web que imitan a la perfección toda la
línea gráfica y el diseño de periódicos
muy conocidos os voy a dar un ejemplo
singapur respalda una cripto divisa
oficial y la establece como su moneda
oficial bbc noticias 13 de marzo 2019
por si alguno se lo estaba pensando no
esta noticia no es de la bbc es de una
web random que imita la página web de la
bbc y es una mentira lo suficientemente
creíble como para que mucha gente se la
crea y la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es pero quién puede estar interesado en
imitar ser un periódico legítimo para
difundir bulos la respuesta está en la
política y esto nos lleva a hablar de
países como
[Música]
exacto la madre rusia existen infinitas
evidencias de que el gobierno ruso ha
creado campañas de news y de bots para
manipular la política de otros países y
no en este caso no sólo estamos hablando
de las elecciones de eeuu en 2016 por
supuesto que en este caso rusia también
intentó manipular la campaña pero por
muchos esfuerzos que pusiera al kremlin
es prácticamente imposible competir con
los medios de un país como eeuu
embargo sabéis cuáles son los países que
más han sufrido los efectos de las
picnics pues no no son ni eeuu ni ningún
otro gran país hablamos de los países
bálticos pensadlo bien son países muy
pequeños y con medios muy pequeños y con
poco presupuesto basta con que el
kremlin haga una inversión mínima para
crear medios de propaganda que compitan
mano a mano con los medios locales
[Música]
de hecho en la capital de letonia en
riga hay un centro especial de la otan
para combatir la desinformación y aquí
es donde empezamos a hablar de temas
serios las técnicos se han convertido en
un problema geopolítico un problema que
muchos quieren solucionar con leyes la
pregunta es cómo pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
drive
políticos luchando contra la mentira si
pensabas que este título es todo un
oxímoron esperad porque aún no habéis
visto nada cuál diría es que ha sido uno
de los primeros países en legislar
contra las facebook venga a pensar la
respuesta
rusia aprueba una ley para prohibir las
técnicas y los insultos online a
oficiales del gobierno financial times 7
de marzo 2019 a que esta no es la bella
y venidera y no penséis que esta ley es
papel mojado en mayo de 2021 rusia
amenazó con prohibir twitter si no
cumplía con su ley al final la historia
terminó con que rusia pidió a las
empresas de telecomunicaciones que
redujeran la velocidad con la que se
cargaba twitter en el país y ya sé lo
que me diréis todos vale esto es lo que
ocurre en rusia pero qué está pasando en
el mundo democrático pues atentos porque
ahora vamos a viajar
[Música]
alemany la semana pasada ya os contamos
como las autoridades alemanas tienen una
larga historia denunciando a periodistas
no sólo es porque quieran evitar
discursos neonazis es que también hay
denuncias por supuestas bake news
atentos la autoridad reguladora
financiera alemana presenta una denuncia
criminal contra el financial times the
telegraph 17 de abril de 2019 y os
preguntaréis pero por qué alemania
denunció al financial times es muy
simple por haber destapado el escándalo
de wild-card si queréis la historia
completa os la contamos aquí en visual
política hace casi un año tenéis el
vídeo en la descripción ya sabéis que
aquí en visual político somos muy dados
a las teorías de la conspiración
precisamente pero tenemos que reconocer
que muchos escándalos como por ejemplo
el watergate o el escándalo wild-card
empezaron siendo precisamente esos
teorías de la conspiración y aquí es
donde llega el gran debate
[Música]
las técnicas son un problema
absolutamente pero como sabemos
distinguir lo que es pec news de lo que
no es pequeños quién puede dictar lo que
es la verdad de verdad podemos confiar
ciegamente en lo que dice la
organización mundial de la salud podemos
fiarnos ciegamente de lo que dicen los
reguladores financieros alemanes podemos
fiarnos de los muchos epidemiólogos de
distintos países que aseguraban que el
coronavirus no sería un problema por
supuesto ya sé lo que me diréis muchos
todo el mundo tiene derecho a cometer
errores pero precisamente por eso es tan
peligroso darle a unas pocas
instituciones el poder de censurar lo
que creen que es mentira y precisamente
por eso por lo difícil que es hacer
leyes en contra de las técnicos la unión
europea está mirando en esta dirección
la comisión europea cree que la
autorregulación es el mejor camino para
lidiar con las pequeños garrigues news
25 de junio 2018 si habéis visto el
vídeo anterior de esta serie ya conocéis
los peligros que tienen la autocensura
en algunos casos puede ser incluso peor
que la censura impuesta directamente por
un gobierno pero la pregunta la
auténtica pregunta es cómo puede
funcionar un modelo así si recordáis las
tres mayores plataformas de contenido
online son facebook donde está también
instagram twitter y youtube que como
sabéis son parte del grupo alphabet que
es donde también está google la pregunta
es de verdad hablamos de empresas tan
distintas pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
y en censura en internet hoy voy a
contar una anécdota personal como sabéis
visual polític tiene un perfil de
'twitter' con 60.000 seguidores llevamos
más de 5 años con ese perfil sin embargo
todavía no hemos conseguido que twitter
nos verifique la cuenta es decir que
técnicamente podría llegar cualquiera y
crearse un perfil con nuestro nombre y
nuestra foto de avatar y hablar como si
fuera visual político y diréis porque no
estamos verificados en twitter pues lo
cierto es que nadie lo sabe hemos
preguntado por todas partes cómo se
verifica un perfil y la respuesta
siempre es la misma tienes que conocer a
alguien de la empresa que te haga el
favor si habéis oído bien twitter una de
las redes sociales más grandes del
planeta funciona como si fuera el
restaurante de tu barrio y todo esto
tiene una explicación
[Música]
fijaos en este dato en el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo las acciones de
twitter en bolsa valen 66 dólares las de
facebook están en 361 dólares y las de
alphabet que ya os hemos dicho es el
grupo donde está google y youtube valen
agarrados a la silla 2700 dólares para
que os hagáis una idea twitter tiene 5
mil 500 empleados en todo el mundo
facebook tiene unos 60 mil y alphabet
tiene más de 132 mil empleados y diréis
pero todo esto que tiene que ver con las
facebook pues mucho porque hacer un
filtro que modere efectivamente y de
forma justa a las facebook es muy caro y
requiere todo un ejército de
programadores youtube puede permitírselo
otras empresas tienen que recurrir a
unas prácticas un tanto más
cuestionables y aquí es donde volvemos a
la foto del principio fijaos en los
distintos ceos la de tipo el de facebook
y el de twitter os presento a jack
dorsey considerado por varios medios
financieros como uno de los peores ceos
de todo eeuu
para que os hagáis una idea incluso
muchos activistas de twitter han llegado
a planificar revueltas internas para
echarlo y diréis pero de verdad es tan
terrible este hombre pues bien desde el
principio y actor si no quiso que su
empresa diera beneficios si habéis oído
bien la idea original era que twitter
fuera una especie de fundación ong al
estilo de la wikipedia una especie de
servicio público de hecho twitter tiene
una larga tradición colaborando con el
gobierno de los eeuu y lo cierto es que
jack dorsey ha llegado a decir
públicamente que lo suyo es la política
atentos ya héctor 60 de twitter quiere
ser alcalde de nueva york cnn 18 de
marzo 2013 y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos bueno y dónde está el
problema desde cuándo es malo no querer
que tu empresa de beneficios pues el
problema es muy simple si no quieres
mancharse las manos con el sucio dinero
no puedes mantener una plantilla grande
de trabajadores y si no tienes
programadores y a la vez quiere es poder
sacar pecho con una red social 100%
libre de contenido dañino terminas con
cosas como ese
twittea suspende la cuenta de la actriz
rose mcgowan después de que hable en
contra del abuso sexual gizmodo 10 de
diciembre de 2017 existen miles de casos
de cuentas suspendidas en twitter sin
razón aparente cuentas que se vuelven a
activar en algunos casos a los pocos
días por ejemplo en el año 2016 twitter
borro cuentas que habían sátira de
políticos rusos días después volvieron a
aparecer y diréis por qué pues nadie lo
sabe los criterios de twitter para
borrar cuentas son totalmente
arbitrarios por comparar youtube tiene
un algoritmo que sigue unas reglas muy
claras y esas reglas están publicadas en
la propia página de youtube si tenéis un
canal de youtube y nunca habéis leído
estas reglas las encontrareis en los
enlaces de la descripción además youtube
también ofrece cursos para los creadores
donde se puede ver muy claro lo que se
puede hacer y lo que no se puede hacer
también te explican que puede estar
monetizado y que no puede estar
monetizado por si todo esto fuera poco
existe un sistema de apelaciones es
decir que si mañana youtube quitará este
vídeo yo podría enviar una solicitud y
puedo deciros por experiencia propia que
el sistema de apelaciones funciona al
menos yo personalmente conozco dos
canales que fueron recuperados tras un
proceso de apelaciones por cierto que si
estáis viendo este vídeo y tenéis un
canal que acaban de manejar también
podéis encontrar el link para
recuperarlo en la descripción y por
cierto que hablando de youtube este es
un momento perfecto para recordaros que
aquí en visual politics sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones pero volvamos
con nuestra historia
[Música]
en ello tuve el mejor sistema de
moderación de contenido del mundo
posiblemente no pero al menos es un
sistema en el caso de twitter hay muy
poco de sistematización de hecho hay
muchos canales en youtube que están
permitidos dentro de youtube pero que
tienen su cuenta baneada en twitter este
es el caso por ejemplo de un tío blanco
hetero que es un canal español que habla
de opinión política evidentemente como
todos los canales de opinión política es
controvertido pero también es uno de los
más grandes de este tema en todo youtube
españa sin embargo en twitter ha sido
eliminado y baneado varias veces es más
es que lo ha intentado varias veces pero
siempre le quitan la vida
[Música]
de hecho las políticas para bloquear
cuentas de twitter son tan arbitrarias
que incluso varían de un país a otro en
eeuu con europa el enemigo es el
discurso del odio y las pequeños pero en
turquía por ejemplo el enemigo son todos
los políticos que se opongan a erdogán
no me creéis pues echad un vistazo a
esta noticia en una revisión de más de
700 cuentas retenidas en turquía más de
seiscientas pertenecían a los militantes
de movimientos pro kurdos y afiliados al
predicador islámico de tula google en el
gobierno turco culpa al bullying de sus
seguidores de tener un rol en el golpe
de estado de 2016 básket news 24 de
enero 2018 y si el sistema ya funciona
mal de por sí las propuestas de mejora
son aún peores os presentamos bird watch
una estrategia basada en la comunidad
para combatir la desinformación twitter
blog 25 de enero de 2021 esta estrategia
para combatir la desinformación consiste
atentos en un grupo de tuiteros
seleccionados por el propio twitter que
se dedicarán a denunciar tuits que
desinformen la empresa ya está haciendo
pruebas en eeuu con unos 100
verificadores que según ya han dicho
vienen de distintas ideologías dicho de
otra forma que a falta de dinero para
herramientas twitter recurre a gente
física que verifique las noticias y aquí
es donde volvemos a la idea del
principio no sólo estamos hablando de
libertad de expresión también hablamos
del trabajo de mucha gente porque detrás
de muchas de esas cuentas grandes de
twitter o de youtube o de facebook o de
instagram está el modo de vida de mucha
gente como os podéis imaginar dejar todo
esto en manos del capricho de un grupo
de personas presionadas por políticos
riesgos ideológicos y por qué no decirlo
enemistades personales no es una buena
idea además hablamos de miles de
millones de reportes y una persona
humana no puede
gestionarlos todos necesitas en algún
momento alguna forma de algoritmo
dicho de otra forma que tal vez no
deberíamos plantearnos y las plataformas
deben autorregularse o no sino si las
plataformas deben garantizar los
derechos de los creadores y en este
sentido tenemos que decir que no todas
las plataformas actúan igual así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
queréis que las plataformas de internet
deberían hacer un mayor esfuerzo para
evitar las pequeños o tal vez deberían
hacer justo lo contrario y permitir
cualquier tipo de contenido y lo que es
más importante creéis que twitter
debería responder ante sus usuarios por
tener unas prácticas tan arbitrarias
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios por cierto que si queréis
profundizar en este tema de las técnicas
os dejo una conferencia que dio nuestro
querido compañero de canal enrique couto
os la dejo aquí en la descripción y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
y darle la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]